cet avion est une pièce de musée mais
une pièce de musée qui volera à nouveau
75 ans jour pour jour après le
débarquement de normandie le 6 juin 1944
auxquels il a participé un grand jour
pour le propriétaire de ce tc3 lui
michael mcbride qui a sauvé l'avion avec
ses ouvriers de buffalo airways
compagnie des territoires du nord-ouest
et des bénévoles passionnés dont des
étudiants de l'école nationale
d'aérotechnique où il se trouve
actuellement
il a été trouvé près de l'aéroport de
saint-hubert dans cet état-là lourdement
vandalisés nous avons sauvé pour honorer
la mémoire des héros du débarquement de
normandie cet avion me survivre benoît
demulder à superviser tous les travaux
de restauration à l'école
d'aérotechnique c'est à paris là en
particulier a été construit en janvier
1944 à oklahoma city aux états unis
après ça il a été transféré à la royal
air force à montréal à dorval au mois
février 1944 convoyés par les airs
jusqu'aux en angleterre est versée au
sco dont 260 euros avec le sco dont 271
de la royal air force cet avion là
participé à des opérations majeures
de la seconde guerre mondiale donc on
parle pas du type on parle vraiment de
cet appareil là
le dogue le dakota c47 comme on le bâti
c'est à l'époque porté les couleurs de
la royal air force avec les barres
noires et blanches typiques du jour j
meneur monde donc il a fait le
débarquement en normandie à 23h50 le 5
juin dont il a décollé en angleterre et
à l'arrêt de cette page triste au dessus
de la normandie
parmi les 17 personnes en à la moitié
qui sont pas cons pas survécu
l'avion lui-même a été touché par la dca
allemande mais il a pu regagner
l'angleterre où il a largué des hommes
du ravitaillement transporter des
blessés jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
retour à la vie civile chez canadair à
montréal pour servir de transport de
passagers à l'ancêtre d'air canada
transcanada airlines est terminée jusque
dans les années 80 aux services de
transports canada dont on lui a redonné
les couleurs le vert de l'aileron c'est
celui de ben flow airways dont la flotte
compte huit décès 3 on a gardé à travers
le temps une grande affection pour le
dc3 on dit d'une manière générale que le
meilleur avion pour remplacer un dc3
basse et un dc3 pourquoi parce qu'il est
difficile de faire aussi performant
aussi simple de maintenance c'est un
gros ego le dc3 c'est un avion qui est
stable c'est un avion qui
pardonne facilement les erreurs des
pilotes alors pour la technologie de ces
années là c'était ce qu'on pourrait
qualifier de roswell en tant qu'avion
quel oiseau le dc3 cité l'avion de son
père paul émile pilotes et fondateur de
québec et en 1946 tout le monde ici fait
un devoir de mémoire mais il y a plus
que ça pourquoi il faut les restaurer je
pense que c'est l'histoire
aujourd'hui on a des jeunes de l'école
ici qui font du travail bénévole et qui
en touchant l'avion sont curieux de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé avec cet
avion là donc on remonte dans le temps
et de bien comprendre l'histoire je
pense que ça aide à mieux préparer le
futur
les bénévoles met les dernières touches
en prévision du premier vol comme c'est
tous des bénévoles et volontaires
on a un plaisir autrement ne travaille
et l'avionique a été refaite
complètement
on a remis une plaque avec son numéro de
série d'origine le 12 253 de lusine d'un
gloss d'oklahoma city
il a fait sa sortie du hangar la veille
du spectacle aérien de l'aéroport de
saint-hubert en bonne compagnie
celle d'un spitfire d'époque
fameux chasseurs britanniques de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
les moteurs ont déjà tourné ils sont
enfin prêts ce décès 3 historique n'a
pas volé depuis 27 ans jean michel
leprince est du canada
saint-hubert